Abdul baset may not serve his entire
sentence there is no early release or
prisoner exchange he has cancer and it's
getting
worse his wife zubeda says she wakes up
every day expecting bad
news with the war restarting we're
losing hope I always try to be strong in
front of my children but I expect the
worst even the kids are disappointed my
son asks if his father can take much
more of this if the ceasefire is over
what's going to happen to sick
prisoners did he go to that treatment
stories photographs and medical reports
are all she has to connect her children
with their father a man who has spent a
decade in and out of jail no charges no
sentence a man who needs medical
attention he's not getting in an Israeli
cell Palestinians are always just a
moment away from tragedy the end of the
ceasefire in Gaza on Friday within
minutes of Israeli guns coming back to
life fresh Horrors and hopes crushed
that more prisoners will be
freed ahid is serving a life sentence
for his part in the killing of an
Israeli minister in
2001 it is unlikely he will ever be
released but his wife says hope does not
care about the
odds we're very sad that releasing some
Prisoners has come at such a high price
we're talking about 20,000 killed those
who were retrieved and others still
under the rubble that's a very very high
cost freedom is precious but we were
hoping that they would be released in a
deal of some sort without all this
Bloodshed and brutality inflicted on our
people in
Gaza behind bars but not forgotten to
Israel criminals terrorists security
threats to Palestinians fathers and
husbands who write love letters Patriots
who fight for
Freedom Zay basravi Al jazer rala in the
occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer